ahora que ya sabes qué son las secciones
cónicas y por qué se llaman de esa forma
veamos si podemos entender las
ecuaciones de las cónicas un poco mejor
y usar ese conocimiento para al menos
reconocerla así que por ejemplo si tú
ves la ecuación también entender cómo
graficar la así que vamos a empezar con
la que es creo yo la más fácil de todas
que es el círculo este digamos lacónica
creo yo la más la más sencilla y la más
intuitiva y y esencialmente la ecuación
del círculo se reduce a x cuadrada malla
cuadrada igual a ere cuadrada es decir
son todos aquellos puntos del plano que
si sumas los cuadrados de sus
coordenadas te da un número fijo que es
un número constante y que es cuadrada
verdad entonces a esta r es la que
conocemos como el radio y esta ecuación
lo que me está diciendo es que tengo un
círculo con centro en el origen es decir
en el vector o en el punto cero cero
y esto se puede ver más o menos de esta
forma digamos aquí tengo yo mis ejes
y ahí tengo yo mis ejes entonces voy a
dibujar el círculo con centro en 0 en el
0 0
y ahí está un cuarto de círculo más o
menos hagan mucho uso de su imaginación
para que para que se vea esto como un
círculo ok y este círculo la propiedad
que cumple es que tiene un radio fijo r
entonces todos estos puntos de la línea
verde cumplen que si sumamos sus
coordenadas al cuadrado eso nos da este
número al cuadrado y esto sale la
fórmula del círculo sale de la fórmula
de la distancia y que la fórmula de la
distancia es simplemente una extensión
de lo que es el teorema de pitágoras
verdad entonces estos puntos digamos los
puntos de la forma x
de todos estos puntos son de la forma x
mayer porque son puntos en el plano
digamos distan del 0 0 lo mismo ahora
como calculo yo una distancia
simplemente restó las coordenadas y esto
es x0 al cuadrado
pero al cuadrado verdad y esto es una
distancia al cuadrado porque si yo
sacara la raíz de esto esto es la
fórmula de la distancia elevamos al
cuadrado y nos da cierta distancia al
cuadrado verdad entonces x menos cero
simplemente es equis y esto lo elevamos
al cuadrado y le sumamos ya porque es
menos 0 elche y eso va al cuadrado esto
es una distancia al cuadrado entonces
esta fórmula de la distancia que que
tenemos aquí no es otra cosa más que el
teorema de pitágoras expresado con
coordenadas verdad y que de hecho ya lo
vimos en algunos otros vídeos por
ejemplo vamos a considerar este círculo
digamos x cuadrada massieu cuadrada
igual a 9 entonces como gráfico yo eso
vamos a graficar eso simplemente pongo
mis ejes
y ahí tengo los ejes y esto me dice que
es un círculo con centro en el en el
origen con centro en el cero
ahí tengo un círculo
más o menos ok voy a tratar de dibujar
lo mejor
y está medio círculo
vamos a hacer el otro medio círculo se
ve mucho mejor verdad y ahora tenemos
bueno un radio digamos aquí estén tres
menos tres y tres y menos tres de hecho
cualquier otra distancia que tenga yo
del del origen a cualquier punto del
círculo mide tres ahora esto te
preguntarás porque no es nueve el radio
y es que recuerda que esto de aquí es el
radio al cuadrado es decir el radio al
cuadrado es 9 el radio sin el cuadrado
entonces va a ser 3 verdad sacando raíz
cuadrada de ambos lados y no puede ser
menos 3 porque estamos hablando de
distancias ok entonces vamos a complicar
un poquito el asunto
un poquito no mucho tenemos bueno aquí
tenemos nosotros la ecuación x cuadrada
más cuadrada igual a 3 al cuadrado ok
esto me está diciendo que tengo el
centro centro en el punto cero cero
ahora bien qué pasa si yo quiero este
mismo círculo pero que no tenga centro
en el 0 0 entonces la ecuación por
ejemplo qué pasa si tuviéramos la
ecuación x menos 1 al cuadrado más que
más 2 al cuadrado esto es 3 al cuadrado
ok entonces simplemente simplemente tú a
lo mejor te pones a observarlo y tejer
te te da miedo verdades de expresión es
bastante más complicada y si
desarrollamos los cuadrados podría
volverse una expresión muy muy muy muy
temerosa sin embargo no no hay que
tenerle mucho miedo si si te das cuenta
es como el mismo patrón el x cuadrada lo
sustituir por x menos 1 y el ji cuadrada
lo sustituye por el más 2 entonces sólo
sólo lo que hice fue sustituir
xy está ahí por una nueva variable que
es x1 y la ye por gemma 2
esto me está diciendo que el círculo
está traslada está trasladado verdad y
bueno porque digo eso si digamos si yo
quiero encontrar los puntos que distan 0
es decir que aquí no sea 3 al cuadrado
sino que sean 0 entonces la distancia
entre dos puntos es cero pues si son el
mismo punto entonces como vamos a hacer
que esto nos dé cero pues si cada uno de
estos numeritos es cero porque están
elevados al cuadrado entonces para qué x
menos uno sea cero yo lo que tengo que
hacer es hacer a x igual a 1 verdad
tengo que hacer a x igual a 1 y para que
ye más 12 a 0 pues ya tiene que ser
menos 2 verdad
entonces lo que me está diciendo es que
el centro está en este punto en 1 - 2 a
lo mejor al inicio tú dices oye me cae
que el que el centro está en menos 1 y 2
y casi estarías en lo cierto eso es lo
que la intuición a lo mejor te dice pero
entonces estarías en el lado contrario
es decir estarías en la dirección
contraria ahora entonces aquí estamos
diciendo porque el centro es ahí
simplemente estamos diciendo bueno pues
si queremos encontrar los puntos que
distan 0 del centro procesa el mismo
centro verdad y para que sea 0 cada una
de estas tiene que ser 0 muy bien una
forma quizás un poco más bueno distinta
de cómo identificar esto es que esto es
x menos 1 al cuadrado más que más 2 al
cuadrado esto es lo mismo esto es lo
mismo que el vector de que el punto x
coma y le restamos
1 - 2 ok ya esto le estamos sacando este
esto es lo que le estamos sacando la
distancia digamos que esto no es un
igual solo estamos haciendo esta
diferencia de estos dos puntos y justo
es más o menos la idea que teníamos
anteriormente ahora como vemos que esto
está trasladado bueno pensemos digamos
por ejemplo para qué valores se cumple
que que esto es digamos digamos que
puede ser que ya es 2 gay y es 2 o que
la altura
la altura es 2
ok entonces si yo quiero que la altura
sea 2 es decir que yo sea igual a 2 pues
por ejemplo nos ponemos por aquí ya
cantaremos déjenme ponerlo con otro
color andaremos aquí con cuando la
altura es 2 verdad entonces nos
colocamos ahí ahora bien si yo tengo el
mismo círculo pero ahora tengo el centro
en uno menos dos digamos aquí está el
uno y aquí está el menos dos lo voy a
poner con el mismo color azul aquí tengo
el centro muy bien entonces vamos a
tratar de dibujar esto de la mejor forma
que podamos
ok eso no salió muy bien
por aquí
de esta forma ahí tenemos el círculo
vamos a hacer un último intento
más o menos ahí tenemos nuestro círculo
más o menos entonces ahora nos
preguntamos cuándo esta altura por
ejemplo es
cuando este numerito de aquí es 2 verdad
así lo hicimos para este caso ahora me
pregunto cuando yemas 2 es 2 pues cuando
llegue 0 verdad entonces cuando hoy es 0
es justamente estos dos que corresponden
de forma análoga a estos dos puntos es
pero eso no te haya confundido mucho
puedes incluso también memorizar la
fórmula verdad sólo te tomas estos dos
numeritos les cambias el signo y esos
corresponden a nuestro centro nuevo
verdad y me parece que ya se me está
acabando el tiempo vamos a parar aquí
pero en el próximo vídeo empezaremos
ahora a hablar de elipses